jennifer lopez is shutting down reports
that she's upset over ben affleck's
recent comments about his ex-wife
jennifer garner i was trapped you know i
was like i can't leave because of my
kids but i'm not happy
earlier this week the last dual star
appeared on sirius xm's the howard stern
show and opened up about his marriage to
the 49 year old actress and how
alcoholism affected their relationship
what do i do and what i did was like you
know drink a bottle of scotch or fall
asleep with a couch which turned out not
to be the solution well affleck caught a
lot of flack for all that on social
media and he later clarified his
comments during a stop by jimmy kimmel
live that's not true i don't believe
that it's the exact opposite of who i am
what i believe and i would never
want my kids to think i would ever say a
bad word about their mom because this
really upset you i mean obviously
amid the backlash reports quickly
surfaced that lopez was offended by what
he had said in his interview with stern
but over the weekend she told people
magazine that's quote simply not true
quote it is not how i feel the hustlers
star who rekindled her relationship with
the oscar winner earlier this year added
quote i couldn't have more respect for
ben as a father a co-parent and a person
and lopez she was snapped supporting the
actor at his taping of the late night
talk show before he attempted to set the
record straight i had gone on and said
like
how much we respect each other and cared
about each other and cared about our
kids and put them first and went through
our stuff and he said that i had blamed
my ex-wife my alcoholism and that i was
trapped in this [ __ ] like just made me
out to be like the worst most
insensitive stupid awful guy garner and
affleck share three children together
sixteen-year-old violet twelve-year-old
seraphina and nine-year-old samuel they
were married in 2005 and split in 2018.
a decision he told stern was amicable
for both of them we grew apart we had a
marriage that didn't work this happens
it's somebody i love and respect
but to whom i was i shouldn't be married
any longer and we said you know what we
don't want ultimately we we tried we
tried we tried because we had kids and
then we said we both of us felt like we
don't want this to be the model that our
kids see of marriage and during his chat
with kimmel affleck said that while he
doesn't mind being turned into a meme
from time to time when it comes to his
family he draws the line and even being
the subject of that is just sort of the
cost of doing business a little bit as
an actor but like not with my kids don't
do that it's wrong it hurts me and your
family
e.t chatted with ben earlier this month
at the premiere of his new flick tender
bar where he opened up about the
intensity of life in the spotlight in my
life
i've been through a lot of different
kinds of experiences with the press and
it's just a it's like a function of what
you do right it's not my favorite part
of the job it's not what i would choose
to do but it is a responsibility in mind
i take seriously and you know you have
to promote this work as for lopez she
was there to show her support on the red
carpet
and while affleck has played coy about
their relationship i don't know if you
are aware of how good the internet
thinks you look it's like all everyone's
talking about lately i think you might
be no i'm not
i'm really not ben um i is it the jlo
glow like how much happiness is she
bringing into your life because you're
looking good man is it the corduroy is
that what she was big on the quarter
because i wasn't sure about where they
told me it's fall he did open up about
reigniting the flame with lopez during
his chat with stern admitting that all
the negative media attention back in the
day was partially responsible for their
2004 split i would say it was about 50
like the idea that
people hate you
and they hate you together and that
being together is poison and ugly and
toxic and thing none of us want to be
part of and who would want to have them
to dinner and what the [ __ ] are they
doing together
and all that echoes what the singer told
et back in 2014.
it was my first like adult heartbreak
was it because it was so public and we
wanted to know every single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help we were about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak fast forward to 2021 and the
two are very much back on and a source
previously told et that the lovebirds
are enjoying blending their families i
do love that of course lopez shares 13
year old twins max and emmy with her ex
mark anthony
quote their goal is to be one big happy
family they both feel like this was
really meant to be jen and ben are all
about their kids and they are having so
much fun together as a big family
everyone is getting along great and
things are really working out for them
on so many levels
[Music]
you